pop
[Musique]
à 3 heures du matin oui madame la
princesse ou i3 certes sonné à santa
maría match là moi qui croyais les époux
princiers croissante au large du
péloponnèse
les voilà qui surgissent à mes yeux en
pleine nuit sans tambour ni trompette
je n'ai rien entendu de dominer mais le
frontal et soeurs a tout déclenché à
florence s'avoue meubles aisément la
nuit c'est le quatrième mariage de son
excellence le prince en zone à chaque
nouveau mariage je suis un peu plus
nerveux et madame 1 c'est soit bien
comme en inquiétudes étaient fondées
sans retour brusquer me tarabuste moi
aussi tu faisais fixe enfin semblé fils
heureux tous les deux fatigués la mer
sans doute son excellence la jeune
princesse se répète et je tombe de
sommeil en regardant mon fils dans les
yeux je n'ai pas fixé ce détail voici
capital 12 mp capitale je tombe de
sommeil
cette phrase dans la bouche d'une femme
a un sens tous différents selon qu'elle
est vitale écoutant les yeux ou au
contraire en les tournant j'étais tout à
ma consternation que madame la princesse
ans après les autres retours les fleurs
le cortège des trompettes et tous ces
motifs de décoration aussi délicat qui
semble être poussées sur les pas du
prince un soul
si on sait pas s urs en offrant sur son
salon n'y pouvons rien madame la
princesse je sais la fidélité des
domestiques et son emprise sur celle des
femmes est là et bien maintenant tous
ces pays il faut vous renée leprince
retrouver tout le monde à son poste au
palais s'est fait madame la princesse
s'est fait le passeur levasseur de
manucure sont des appartements attendant
le réveil de son excellent nom les
chauffeurs dans la grande cour les
secrétaires dans la salle de minerve et
le médecin vient d'arriver et il n'est
pas on se met je vous félicite
non ce n'est pas moi que madame la
princesse doit féliciter c'est monsieur
lucho et lucho bien fait avant d'aller
me recoucher j'ai pris soin de le
réveiller là se bornent mon mérite
s'envole au dessus on lui aussi devait
dormir comme un enfant comme un enfant
madame la princesse
dans les bras de marie mais là mais
comme un enfant deux enfants réunit tous
ces gens qui se croyait en vacances en
quelques heures
et dans notre pays monsieur lucho n'a
pas son pareil dans tous florence il
avait son père
où est il mais il est mort madame la
princesse oui ça je sais son père est
mort merci giuseppe merci de me le
rappeler
non je vous demande où est monsieur
lucho il se repose
infatigables ils reçoivent un
journaliste internaute you grâce à lui
et à son infatigable présence dans cette
maison il semble toujours revoir le
comte pérou gino son père à qui il
ressemble trait pour trait celle-ci
émouvants ou souvenez vous de lui vous
avez fait le compte perugini ma mémoire
avec l'aja beaucoup bus sur deux a à
peine autorise à vous souvenir du conte
de perrault jean dans ce cas je me
souviens madame la princesse ainsi je ne
vous dis pas à vous à qui je
n'apprendrai rien que le comte mérou
gino reste un de mes plus chers
souvenirs à qu'il déroge pas à son fils
évidemment est évidemment encore que
monsieur lucho on serait peut-être
troubler ce jeune homme a des sentiments
d'une exceptionnelle des dix capirex
l'actionnaire nous tiens il paraît que
c'est vous qu'il faut féliciter et de
quoi de la carotte
ils mirent acquis accomplis par votre
zèle à zone va retrouver sa maison à
pied d'oeuvre comme simon attendions
depuis un mois je ne fait que remplir
des fonctions pour lesquelles je suis
rétribuer largement même via l'eau sur
youtube que pensez vous de ce retour
précipité précipités aux avancées
simplement un votre optimisme toujours
comme votre père ce n'est pas un
reproche mais à chacun de ces mariages
avaient même cru oui ou non la zone
étaient tombés sur un ange du ciel
qu'elle ait entraîné dans le sillage
d'un bonheur éternel on c'est exact je
les crues est lui aussi et vous même en
emmenant moi non moi je souhaite à
nuance sauf pour la deuxième parce que
cette danseuse mexicaine n'est même pas
voulu avoir
hassoun a pu avancer son retour pour
mirror's edge of twilight
puis le baril legta
non jamais lanari le princess peut ne
pas supporter la mer c'était le cas de
la première rappelez-vous les princesses
olga la princesse soldats ne pouvaient
pas supporter la mer parce qu'elle était
tombée amoureuse d'un membre de
l'équipage et vu la difficulté qu'il y
avait pour eux à se rencontrer à la
barbe des zones à bord d'une embarcation
de dimension somme toute réduite ou bien
il leur tardait de revenir à terre ce
qui se comprend d'ailleurs l'équipage
depuis cet incident était entièrement
renouvelé j'ai même réussi à recruter
une véritable collection de monstres
jusqu'au capitaine qui est borgne et
pied bovins sais quelle horreur encore
qu'avec les goûts qu'ont les femmes
aujourd'hui ça ne soit plus un thé
l'apaisement
la princesse axel la dernière en date à
quitter la zone pour suivre un labo et
c'était la primauté a fallu une miss
norvège les vrais noblesse se contente
d'une province à celle là il faut tout
le pays et bien lucho relâché at-on les
mondiale mais vous savez comment l'appel
dans le monde
le prince qu'occupe n'ayons pas peur
d'emprunter au peuple son langage
lorsqu'il nous juge
mon fils est une des trois premières
fortunes du monde mais c'est un cocu
mondiale
l'automobile et il faut que l'on fasse
une confidence au fond vous auriez pu
être mon fils au plus tôt j'aurais pu
être votre mère et ça revient au même
non pas tout à fait 18 ans moi carlo
casini valley j'étais la plus belle
fille de toscane jenny parc une des plus
belle jeudi la plus belle je crois sans
peine son père mais les idées mali était
ruinée et label carnot tanout épouse est
à zoug 4 grands noms des gifs de grandes
fortunes grand âge aussi et mondial à
5-4 le fut comme asus a abaissé par les
yeux mon petit la vieille égyptiens ne
pouvait pas combler tous les voeux d'une
belle petite contesti n'a de sens
florentin mes tenues par des liens avis
on pouvait en douter à côté de loin du
rhin et comment sinon garantir une aussi
longue fidélité
mais je vous choque peut-être vous êtes
si jeune si pur si intransigeant et si
naïf aussi mon père
oui oui votre père votre char et nous
dévions et bien loupiots je voulais en
venir à ceux ci c'est que la nature des
femmes est étrangement en fait voilà que
les remords inconnu autrefois je les
éprouve aujourd'hui chaque fois qu'a
sonné trahi je suis atteinte et je
souffre à travers le fils le mal même
que je flippais opère c'est odieux
il faut que cela cesse et bien sonné
jeune yacine et charmant la zone est
fabuleusement riches
c'est injuste enfin il ya l'honneur je
suis né in ivaldi soit mais je suis
princesse aegon et je ne veux pas les
pains sa zone soit coquille de peyrens
vraiment plus de la carotte sans pain
vous son excellence le président
décembre dans la presse
déjà nous n'avons rien décidé tu sais
mais de quelle humeur actifs massacrante
madame la princesse son excellence m'a
donné l'ordre de renvoyer tout le monde
déjà le coiffeur le masseur de manucure
sont repartis sans ouvrir leurs trousses
même les secrétaires avec un logo vision
toute cette affaire c'est ce que je me
suis permis de faire observer à son
excellence qui m'a répondu qu'elle s'en
foutait je cite
et son médecin se souvient-il au moins
que son médecin à des résultats
d'analysés d'examen lui communiquer son
excellence m'a dit je cite encore
qu'elle se foutait aussi de créer du
lien et sa mère son excellence m'a
demandé des nouvelles de madame la
princesse mais elle n'a pas manifesté le
désir de l'avoir j'ai le regret de 10 et
monsieur nous tiens seul monsieur lucho
est prié de rester exécuter vos a été
renvoyé et bien jeanne optimiste lieu
donné galope je pense mon dieu qu'une
grosse mer et la fatigue d'une mauvaise
nuit peuvent être une bonne raison
empêtré farm entente était encore plus
que votre père
en tout cas moi je pense à l'action
quelles actions donné que l'autre celle
qui préludent à toutes les guerres les y
en a mais donne car l'autre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis heureux de vous retrouver en
bonne santé ma mère et toi aussi lucho
au monfils n'avez-vous pas dans les
ordres de l'écolo non sans un mouvement
de lâcheté auquel je ne veux pas céder
jeu set avant ceux qui vont me dire ceci
pour m'annoncer marine et celui là ma
mort mais qu'il parle aux écoutes et un
zoom office nous regardent et laissent
regarder c'est la consternation se lit
sur leurs visages comme sur le vôtre ma
mère et sur celui de lucho il faudrait
être aveugle et je suis tout sauf
aveugle tout
oui tout pourquoi pour rien bon vent
rapport messieurs mais soyez bref s'il
vous plaît je sais quels sacrifices je
demande à des gens de ce pays en les
privant de parler mais vous vous
rattraperez entrevous bon philippines
c'est la ruine
non alors deux choses l'une où je suis
moins riches où je le suis autant je ne
suis plus plus et lance bien pouvoir
afghan
et vous monsieur ces examens où ils sont
négatifs où ils sont positifs mais
captifs excellence bien le fit donc
encore plus riche
je me porte de mieux en mieux je
décidément beaucoup de chance vous
remercie monsieur beaucoup c'est un
soulagement
en ce qui concerne votre santé dont il
est parfois permis de s'inquiéter parce
que pour la fortune si une forte comme
la vôtre n'allait pas augmenter
il n'y aurait plus rien à comprendre
notre société mère savourer j'aimerais
parler seul à seul avec lucho ambiant
rien attendre audrey mais il me semble
qu entre votre pessimisme et l'optimisme
de youtube à pondération r15 je vais me
préparer à accueillir la nouvelle
princesse nouvelle belle fille mon dieu
comment s'appelle-t-elle déjà la
princesse jeunes gens vont la princesse
jalbert mon dieu c'est vrai nom français
[Applaudissements]
je me suis cocu pardon tu m'a très bien
entendu n'ai pas peur de le dire mais
enfin une fois suffit comme les autres
fois ma mère s'y attend mais pourquoi
c'est la surprise
rien de changé mais mariage se suivent
et se ressemblent un jeune c'est
impossible mais ce qui est impossible
tu ne peux pas être ce que tu dis voyant
j'ai déjà prouvé que si enfin je n'ai
pas rêvé
ta femme et toi avait bien appris le
maire immédiatement après le linge
immédiatement mais vous êtes allés
directement au port directement
nous n'avions n'ai aucun ami à bord
aucun vous n'avez pas fait des escales
pas la moindre
l'équipage était sûr à des monstres je
te félicite vous avez débarqué cette
nuit à 2 heures alors qu'ils auraient pu
et quand assis toi là c'est toi
lucho j'ai autant d'amis que 2 millions
mais je n'avais qu'un toit pour un homme
aussi riche que moi un ami c'est déjà
pas mal
je te dis toujours tout lucho mais alors
que les confidences entre amis rabaisse
l'amour avec toi elle l'élève
quand j'aime une femme tuée tout près de
moins avec moi c'est un peu comme ces
nous aimions tous les deux mais c'est
moi qui épousait c'est à ce point que
souviens toi
lorsque j'ai surpris dolores dans les
bras de ce jean [ __ ] je crois qu'au
fond de moi j'ai vu d'abord mes clés y
est pauvre lucho et rappelle toi je
regardais toujours le moment de
t'apprendre la fugue d'axel c'est
pourquoi lucho aujourd'hui tu me vois
désolé d'avoir à te porter encore ce
coup c'est un coup je ne le cache pas
j'ai vécu pour me parler de geneviève
des accents qui m'avait conquis
de son côté le m'avait fait une
impression des plus favorables une jeune
fille de la bourgeoisie française
éduquer instruite ravissante je me
disais nous faisons enfin un vrai
mariage
nous allons enfin être heureux tout ce
que je me disais quand j'ai demandé la
main de geneviève à son père ce riche
lyonnais que je venais de ruines et sans
le faire exprès eu un sursaut de fierté
je connais ma fille elle n'acceptera
jamais elle accepta sur-le-champ
pourquoi premier mystère
le mariage plus je me marie plus j'ai
d'amis d'amis sommes surtout et puis a
redit à chaque mariage ils n'attendent
même pas la fin de la cérémonie pour
caracoler autour de marié je ne suis pas
à leur pendant que toi le show ce jour
là j'étais tout à notre bonheur moi plus
méfiants j'observais g pierre jeu
furetais jeu surprend soudain geneviève
à l'écart en compagnie d'un de ses jolis
coeurs déjà qu'ils étaient satan
l'olibrius en effet voulait prendre une
avance sur les autres
mais ils pouvaient devant lui une femme
frémissant soul outrage et pourquoi
d'indignation quelle femme
la mienne laquelle geneviève
ah bon c'est elle mais c'est très bien
alors été montré non je me suis cachée
pour ne rien perdre d'une scène aussi
réconfortante
elle n'a qu'à blade son mépris le
menaçant de tout me rapporter ce que le
docteur d'ailleurs un peu plus tard dans
la voiture en roulant vers le port avec
une délicatesse sans que ça prenne un
instant le ton du mouchardage qui était
ce de sans intérêt ainsi je veux savoir
fabrizzi fabrique elle me signale a en
outre toujours avec la même exquise
délicatesse l'outrecuidance d'un autre
postulant parfait lequel collet and co
les halles encore oui encore tu
n'oublies pas mal non plus non mais toi
tu oublies azzoun pourquoi avoir eu la
faiblesse d'inviter un monsieur qui t'a
déjà enlevé une femme à mes yeux c'était
un risque de moins
mais revenons à geneviève et au mystère
de sa conduite au mystère sa loyauté qui
veut dire mettons sa loyauté mystérieuse
oui enfin tout à fait raison bon vous
voilà un bon voilà des monstres et la
mer
riendeau 3d plus d'intimité avec
geneviève c'est la nuit adorable
adorable pour la première fois je
pouvais me croirez mais je cède à la
griserie j'oubliais enfin que je suis la
troisième fortune du monde je ne suis
plus qu'un matelot à bord d'un yacht
même un bon matelot à côté des autres
pauvre à zone alors le lendemain gracq
comment jeudi de lendemains traque pas
du tout quand elle en a tout recommence
en plus mais rien encore
je voulais pouvoir te décrire lucho mon
nom ne décrit pas arrivent le plus
rapidement
à quoi est bien ce que tu as dit ne t'en
patiente pas le troisième jour je vois
un matelot ces prochaines maclou mais
c'est répugnant les autres encore mais
cela c'était peut-être le plus laid elle
me dégoûte
excuse moi bien les pires que les eaux à
temps elle était bien caché derrière un
cabestan le fioul en lasse elle se
laisse aller et c'est d'attendre mon
dieu ce n'est pas les gouttes on pensait
que c'était moi c'était toi
et oui puisque un message aussi toutes
ses bras en poussant un cri et l'uaw a
obtenu une gifle à direct l boxx les
merveilleux j'ai même pas eu le temps
d'intervenir en direct qui manquent de
faire passer notre homme par dessus bord
magnifique il était pas mal
alors tu t'es montré non non au gel dans
l'ombre une joie bien naïve milan des
jeux là vous joie que je voulais
savourer - tout seul pour le plus cruel
et le savourer mon pauvre azzoun à l'est
var arrive je suis impatient présent à
écoute fait comme moi il a fallu
patienter mais aussi et d'abord les
heures sont longues que je te prie de
croire c'est qu'avec geneviève rien ne
se passait comme avec les autres avec
geneviève la mystérieuse le mot tromper
allait enfin prendre sa pleine
signification
le lendemain non le soir pardon le soir
je la trouve bizarre fillon tenir vezo
bord que je ne sais quel aveu contenu
nous y sommes
où sommes nous tu t'interroges oui elle
éclate en sanglots oui elle te dis
qu'elle a un amant
non non écoute l'autre chaud je t'assure
tu dois mieux c'est parler c'est
beaucoup plus mystérieux voyons beaucoup
plus mystérieux elle le dit
je vous aime oui mais ne t'emballe pas
je vous aime mais à quoi bon vous ne me
croirez jamais et là dessus le parle de
se jeter à la mer fièvre tremblements
sanglots je passe la nuit à son chevet
effroyable nous toucher je ne veux pas
qu'on touche y est je me suis rendu
n'est ce pas alors et méprisé moir
accablé mois de votre mépris au matin
elle te dit son nom quel nom nom de son
amant tu veux à tout prix qu'elle était
l'amant enfin un moineau s'énervant la
fin nous serons mystères pas question
d'amour au matin elle se fait soudain
contre moi viens viens je t'aime pardon
viennent je t'appartiens et toi tu as
tout
ce fut fait eric elle s'endormit l'aube
rosissait les hublots
je me disais que s'il y avait au monde
deux hommes plus riche que moi il n'y en
avait pas de plus heureux pas pour
longtemps aux oiseaux pour un sou
car à ce moment là mes yeux tombèrent
sur le sac tel sac ça t'amène à l'est le
sac à main a le don chez moi de
provoquer une vraie panique sans sac là
est subitement joue en rouge tu oublié
le sac mon petit bonhomme
elle aussi elle a un sac un petit ça
compte et où elle cache son vrai visage
où l on enfouit sa petite âme noire
ouvre sa classe ouvre et tu sauras et je
le pense je louvre je foule je fouille
et si tu veux tu as tout va mais l'être
des lettres départ à mon écoute aussi
c'était espérant tum annonce que tu es
ok tu conviens toi même que c'est un peu
comme si nous les tuons ensemble
seulement toi tu sais tout et tu es là à
me tenir sur le gris je trouve un agenda
avec la page du 20 mai le jour de notre
mariage ces simples mots hassoun la vie
commence c'est tout c'est tout
mais alors qu'elle même répartie as tu
été fait aux cubains jeu comme maman est
à personne puis cesse de crier ce mot
tue-tête dont le palais pourquoi
d'ailleurs encore s'imaginer les choses
au point de mystère réfléchi où serait
le mystère pourquoi es tu rentres est un
site web je me vais te le dire non je
vais te le dire moi pourquoi tu es
rentrée tu es rentré parce que tout
allait très bien voilà une femme qui
l'énoncé soupirant couvre les pages de
son agenda de temps non et boxe les
matelots loyauté non mystère
déchirée à l'idée que tu puisse douter
de sa sincérité elle a une crise
scrupules mystère et tulle et pis tu la
surveille tu fouilles son satut scrute
le matelot un bateau passe-t-il au large
tu sautes sûreté jumelles dans l'espoir
de découvrir sur le pont un homme qui
rentrait ta femme et lui ferait des
signes mais non rien geneviève est
irréprochable
cette fidélité commences à te peser et
tu décides de rentrer parce que la vie
de bord manque vraiment trop d'occasions
dé prouver ta femme tu décides de
rentrée afin de pouvoir alimenter à
terre des soupçons plus sérieux tu
rentres pour être enfin connue
la fidh il crié ce mot enfin sur quoi tu
espères bien être ruinés et dévoré par
une maladie mortelle
voilà
tu me connais bien et lucho
c'est vrai je quittais le moment où il
allait faire comme les autres que tu
sais ma fortune au mérite une fortune
colossale mais on n'est pas un colosse
bourthayre geneviève a raison vous ne me
croirez jamais je n'arriverai jamais à
les croire ni haine une autre et même si
par miracle je croyais une femme je
crois qu'au fond elle ne croirait pas
que tu as quoi c'est sans remède je
remercie mon père de cette ruine et qui
peut pas avoir le courage de son robinet
volontairement notre que j'ai pensé mais
je n'ai pas non plus de garantie d'être
aimé alors ils vont encore mieux garder
sa fortune se contenter des marots dit
qu'elle vous offre azzoun tu me répète
souvent dans la nuit de ma fortune lucho
tu es ma lumière n'est ce pas c'est vrai
alors écoute moi écoute moi bien cette
fois je te dis azzoun tués et mais à
force de vivre dans l'ombre de tes
amours j'ai fini par acquérir comme un
sens spéciale avec geneviève je sens
enfin l'amour et avec les autres tu ne
l'avais pas senti jamais ces nouveaux
éclatant oui s'il remarque je sent
l'amour
je suis encore mieux placé que moi pour
le sentir
mais ça ne me rend que plus jaloux tiens
c'est le matin surtout que je suis fou
de jalousie
pourquoi le matin ce n'est parce que
l'oeil admis que veut pas ça lesquelles
monsieur aussitôt pensé à tous ses amis
mais jusque elle n'a pas bon sens elle
n'a pas aux écoutes azzouz maintenant
suffit
l'amour ça se gagne si tu ne veux pas
acheter mérite et puis tu pourrais aussi
un peu penser à moi qui fusent mais tu
te le rappeler moi aussi j'ai envie
d'être heureux tu ne t'es jamais demandé
pourquoi je ne marquais pas c'est à
cause de toi tu donc tu ne seras pas
heureux en mariage je ne pourrais pas me
marier et rieuse je regarde et narguer
malheureux nous serions de cocu au lieu
d'un alors j'attends j'attends des
jeunes on apercevait pas qu'elle égoïste
je fais
alors tu crois vraiment que c'est
l'amour c'est l'amour tu l'appelles
mystère parce que tu ne l'avais jamais
vu
[Musique]
longtemps
l'amour
elle chante qu'est-ce que tu en dis
[Musique]
elle a une voix charmante dans le champ
thaddée tyl c'est la première fois sur
le bateau n'avait jamais chanté oh le
chante problème j'en suis sûr
je l'entends du panama je suis pas sûr
non plus les femmes m'ont donné le rayon
un minable comme suit le passé les bras
autour du cou comme c'est lui caresser
les cheveux a souri à soon as raison je
viens de la voir
elles chantent enfin amoureuse et ce
sont des fleurs qu'elle caresse
qu'est ce que vous dites manière qu'elle
veut ce plan digues corbeilles de fleurs
qu'elle vient de recevoir des chars
camélia et orchidées coller à noé
fabriquer et les caresses les flammes
oui collet à nous ils fabriquent ce sont
justement les deux seuls qu'on ne peut
pas soupçonner de la calotte et pour
quelle raison s'il vous plaît la
princesse geneviève les avait signalé
ajoutait le premier soir pour leur
excessive hardiesse ah oui voilà une
bonne raison de les soupçonner plus que
quiconque
quand je parlais de sa loyauté
mystérieuse naïve je savais bien que le
disait avec geneviève je sens enfin
l'amour avec deux ânes ans ça peut
sentir l'amour oui a plané on va vous
exagérez peut-être coûté la vie à bord
ils ne font pas encore ses arômes et
puis il y en aura pas deux ou trois fois
c'était la règle c'est le jour du
mariage que la jeune mariée et repérer
son amant comme la jeune veuve se
choisissent est un successeur à son
époux le jour de l'enterrement
geneviève elle la roue et se choisit en
même temps un amant et un chandelier un
chandelier oui en chandelier je ne
connaissais pas les classiques français
monfils
et bien c'est un apport surtout avec
votre vocation et quand on épouse une
française un chandelier c'est un son
amant qui se conduit avec ostentation
pour couvrir le vrai plus discret lui
nantais que c'est trés florentin aussi
mais notre influence sur le théâtre
français p bref vous verrez qu les
anneaux et fabrizzi papillonner l'un
après l'autre tour de la belle mais
lequel sera le vrai la mort quand les
anneaux fabrizzi on ne saurait jamais je
le sol et est tout de suite au violent
et c'est tout seul surtout par un drew
moi à ta place
l'ouvrir et mon coeur entre la ruse
encore plus de ruse ou alors la force
bonjour bonjour geneviève vous avez une
voix charmante mais pas encore eu le
plaisir de l'entendre pensait que vous
écoutiez mal il mais sûrement déjà
arrivé de chanter or jamais enfin pas
tant vous m'étonnez et à qui s'adressait
ce champ la colère et wafa brisé
pourquoi cette question présentait comme
il briguait vos faveurs tous les deux
rappelé ben oui mais c'est amusant de
vous pensiez figurez vous que je viens
de recevoir deux magnifique corbeille de
fleurs et de kick justement de fabrique
coller à nos wii ne perd pas de temps
oui c'était la première surprise
j'ai d'abord cru qu'elle était de vous
ces fleurs et je les caressais comme
vous le savez caresser oui
croyant que faisait-elle deux mois oui
sa bouche a non au contraire
quand je me fit le devoir y faire très
très mal épinglé et je vois qu'elle
venait de ces deux lieux
mais quand vous les avez caresser ses
fleurs vous pensiez qu'elle était de moi
oui je voulais dire et vous avez chanté
avant ou après
avant ou après quoi mais après les avoir
car ici ça je n'en sais rien quelle
importance comme je chante depuis mon
rêve voilà donc ce talent au jeu leviev
pardonnez moi mais que ces fleurs n'est
pas été alors vous chantez depuis
motorrad il vous chantez comme ça sans
raison parce que la vie est belle que
vous êtes heureux
or c'est lucho qui a raison je vous dis
mais rien que je suis fou pourquoi
demanderez vous oui pourquoi
mais dites moi
vous les aviez bien remis à leur place
non qui décollait anoeta voté oui alors
pourquoi ces fleurs on n'en voit guère
des fleurs cas une femme qui vous a
laissé l'espoir on en voit aussi des
fleurs à une femme qu'on a pensé pour
s'excuser
oui mais sur leur carte et bien il y
avait avec nous excusent bien sûr qu'est
ce qu'il y avait alors mais rien rien
non rien comme ça burke a collé à nous
ils fabriquent rien d'autre
c'est fantastique
mais que voulez vous qu'ils mettent ils
pouvaient tout de même pas écrire avec
nos excuses son papa mais parce qu'ils
ne sont pas censés savoir que je vous ai
tous répété avec nos excuses auraient
semblé louchats qui louche mais omar sy
pourquoi tant de précautions pour ne pas
sembler lucho maryse et vous plaît et
quelles précautions leur carte sans un
mot il pourrait y avoir nos hommages ne
restait que nos voeux de bonheur nom
vient des cartes blanches quand on
n'écrit rien c'est qu'on a peur de dire
les choses mais quelle source
non là je ne vous crois vraiment que
vous prêtez à ces deux valeureux déjà
défendue est de commencer par les
dénoncer puis vous recevez leurs fleurs
maintenant vous les défendez demain que
ferez vous aux autres qu'elle nous a
écoutés je préfère vous parler net je
sais qu'ils vous allez retrouver
quelques mois je vais retrouver quelques
où ça et il signe à florence et qui dont
un homme connaît annonce abrite iguane
au travail
ce que je sais c'est qu'il ya quelqu'un
et c'est pourquoi vous avez précipité
notre retour vers lequel des deux a dit
soudainement à l'autre en trois parts
dont je vous ai dit 'si nous rentrions à
quoi vous m'avez répondu si vous voulez
nuance
autonome dit à une femme de faire quand
une femme dit un homme de fer comme il
voudra c'est pour qu'il fasse comme elle
le veut elle mais pour retrouver l'homme
auquel vous n'avez pas cessé de penser
pendant toute la croisière s'est passé
si tu pensé un instant vos regards
étaient toujours tourné vers la terre
obstinément vous voulez vous que
j'allais tourner sur mer on regarde vers
la terre et sur terre on regarde vers la
mer on n'y échappe pas combien de fois
vous ai-je surprise en pleine rêverie à
qui pensiez vous avec tant de mélancolie
pouvez vous le dire non non non non non
les femmes ne pense pas
michel marié le compte à sa famille elle
pense à son ami ou alors à un autre
homme et ce triste honneur
et pourquoi ne fallait-il pas que je
vous touche dont on connaissait le vous
étiez braqués sur lui comme l'aiguillé
d'une boussole vers le nord et c'est
pourquoi je vous ai tendu ce piège du
retour a dansé arts
il faut voir comme vous avez sauté
dessus tiens je m'appelle à présent vous
êtes et chippis oui oui vous avez chanté
je croyais que c'était la première pas
tout à l'heure non c'était ce jour-là en
apprenant le retour à florence
vous avez chanté mais ba dum ba un
fronton comme quelqu'un qui ne tient pas
à ce qu'on voit éclater sa joie
je ne suis pas aveugle c'est tout c'est
pas n'existe gdt l'habitude terrible
c'est un existent j'en suis sûr voulant
donner sur aurez vous pleurez vous voyez
mais pourquoi pleurer vous au ministère
pour jour ce mystère c'est votre
jalousie je ne me fait peur quel va être
ma vie si je doit récolter ce que vous
autres femmes enceintes mais moi qui
vous arrive est toute neuve près très
près ce que vous ferez de moi c'est vrai
oui je sais vous vous dites ne m'a
épousée parce que je suis la troisième
fortune du monde
eh bien écoutez moi un zoom cette brèche
s'est dit oui à cause de votre fortune
pour rendre à mon père et au mien ce que
vous leur avez enlevé seulement voilà
depuis il ya eu le yacht est la
troisième fortune du monde n'a plus
existé
il n'ya plus que mon mât
m
regardez moi
regarde moi
c'est toi qui est merveilleuse et c'est
moi qui suis fou répète le jeu serait ce
que vous ferez de moi je serais ce que
vous ferez deux mois oui ce que je ferai
de toi je suis votre femme
tu es ma femme et c'est vous à zoug qui
en ferait une femme fidèle ou un fidèle
oui c'est moi pardon
qu'est ce que vous dites je dis que ma
fidélité est entre vos mains oiseaux ne
commet pas vous pouvez donc envisager de
me tromper
moi non c'est vous qui l'envisagé et
vous semblez tellement convaincu qu'on
finit par être ébranlé c'est fantastique
c'est la première fois que j'entends une
chose pareille et vous me dites ça
tranquillement parce que je suis très
tranquille en est mais que dois je faire
pour que vous en restez fidèle non mais
dites je vous en prie
ça m'intéresse est simple avoir une
telle confiance en moi que l'idée ne
puisse jamais me venir dans la buse et
faire cesser autour de moi cette
surveillance honteuse qui votent rambert
instauré sans perdre et demi à vous avez
déjà remarqué qu'on ne me demande pas de
remarquer une dame de compagnie
attendait quand j'ai ouvert les yeux
pour s'attacher à mais pas chaque porte
cache un domestique et chaque massif un
jardinier et votre mère furète de ci de
là s'en vont jouir du droit du but
c'est là que vous vouliez en venir
et moi qui m'attendent riceys imbéciles
allons coller les fabriquer assez rusé
la force maintenant c'est la
surveillance ne vous gêne
et pourquoi vous gêne-t-elle je vais
vous le dire moi parce que vous voulez
coucher comme les autres comme tout avec
un seul d'ailleurs l'autre c'est 1,1 à
un chandelier voilà un chandelier
je connais vos classiques vous voyez le
voilà le mystère vous voulez coucher et
bien vous le poussera pas couché il faut
rejoindre son complice et s'allonger
quelque part souvent ni vous ne pourrez
jamais le rejoindre et le seul lit sur
lequel vous en mangerez ce sera le mien
vous vivrez tabou au milieu des badauds
tout serrés les uns contre les autres
comme en temps de parole d'une prison
vous le couche n'est pas parce que je
suis plus fort
[Applaudissements]
parler alors
mais vous non
je vous aime être sur l'eau une faible
et la terre c'est un autre que vous vous
destinez maintenant moi je connais un
qui connaissez vous celui qui sera votre
amant ou plutôt tu ne le seras pas
vraiment vous le connaissez et qui s
cole est à nous ou fabrizzi oui mais
voilà le quai
je le ferai la première fortune du monde
ne le sauraient pas prince azur et vous
n'êtes que la troisième
[Applaudissements]
je ne serais je le fais
quant à 12 qu'est ce qu'il dit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
on savait que les journalistes et les
majordomes entre points communs je le
vois pas le cas monsieur victoire tout
savoir
oui mais nous nous gardons tout pour
nous tandis que vous n'est ce pas pour
servir la gloire de vous mettre à
thouars alors monsieur le majordome
réfléchissez oui la gloire et l'honneur
ces bals masqués en l'honneur du retour
des époux princiers
on dit que c'est une idée de la
princesse mer 11 falun gong eu l'idée dé
pas du grand jeu lucho avait toujours de
la princesse et les travestis ne sont
pas d'une seule époque north ballon
c'est un mélange mais uniquement à des
personnages
je viens de français et italiens c'est
amusant à quelle heure les bratton les
masques sur un signal de la princesse
c'est le majordome il faut l'élever bon
dos tout de suite je ne connais pas tout
le monde monsieur bien personnages
principaux me suffiront aux des
comparses s'en doute bien avec qui notre
nero s'acoquine avec la reine d'espagne
le petit haut pour le coupé charmant des
héros cela sûrement c'est la princesse
geneviève
je n'avais jamais vu c'est un début en
quoi est-elle mariam théâtre français
est le nom du caprices de marianne
scaramouche jeter habitat que j'entends
bien mais dessous le chevalier koléa nom
accolé à nos tiens tiens tiens tiens
coléno madame sans gêne des riverains
c'est ce qu'à l'arrêt et aux français et
italiens aussi je crois en eux mêmes du
monde entier c'est le procès soon as non
non non non indiens de moyens et cette
souveraine altière et décidé cette fois
mon pardon et nous c'est une manie si ce
n'est ce pas oui la grande catherine
celles qui faisaient marché français les
italiens et maintenant monsieur je ne
veux plus voir ici pouvoir ici passer
dans le jardin mais à votre excellence
c'est compris tout à fait plus personne
dans cette salle madame leprince
allez-vous vu mon fils a le site oui
aussi
ah le voilà
[Musique]
ce n'est pas le site non non il a changé
oui en voyant la zone lui rien de commun
avec le site pas mais toi tu enlèves qui
change des clameurs c'est exactement ce
qu'il faut mais je mets mieux le 6 mai
que le smur sommes largement ça je ne
sais pas on aura aux costumiers tout à
fait bien ainsi votre femme vous aviez
vu aussi n'est ce pas oui mais vous
n'aviez pas votre masque nous non plus
elle ne peut donc pas à vous reconnaître
ce nouveau travestis et non non et vous
ma mère moi non plus on a vu en
cléopâtre
je suis en médicis nous pouvons
manoeuvrer tranquillement ma mère j'ai
quelques scrupules des scrupules bains
où il était si heureuse de ce bal
pourquoi parce qu'un gars et retrouver
son amant tu sais peut-être va-t-elle
les oublier
résoudre mon fils quand je vous ai dit
collet à la fabrique importe puisqu'il
ne se passera rien vous m'avez répondu
si je veux savoir mais c'est vrai je vis
moi oui mais bon depuis lequel
machination et à mesure qu'elle se
déroulera ma mère j'aimerais que cela ne
fût pas trop vilain monfils au grand
jour il n'y a que le faux visage mais
ton leur démarche et nous aurons les
vrais
oui
[Musique]
c'était le avec la brésil et comment le
savez-vous c'est qu'on ne savait pas
sous quel travail chi à bédié quand les
anneaux de venir à ce bal je me demande
où serait mon plan ah ben tu vois ton
plan c'est de permettre à la femme de
leur parler tranquillement à l'abri des
masques bravo online et wissem à rihanna
mais pourtant didier collet a lancé
jean-pierre marielle à se lancer avec un
seul ou avec les deux avec les deux et
ils ont marché comme un seul homme n'ont
pas été surpris d'être identifié cela tu
es ma dame la princesse lalla 101 pays
si oui mais ma mère e fabrice zicola
nous vont voir qu'elles sont deux
marianne dans ce panneau déjà vu mais il
croit que c'est l'autre la faux c'est la
première chose que j'aurais dit mais
après c'est vrai qu'il a bien joué son
rôle jusqu'au bout
enfin jusqu'au bout de la langue je
pense ce n'était pas facile
il était très enflammé tous les droits à
est très charmant mais moi je pencherais
pour le pont fabrizzi oui bah on te
demande ben oui tout ça c'est bien joli
ma mère mais ça ne lui dis toujours pas
vers lequel début je le pense la science
à nous dit déjà qu'ils n'ont pas été
très surpris pour des gens qu'elle avait
soi-disant rabroué sociaux n'est
d'ailleurs qu'un raffinement dans mon
plan vous ne pouvez pas comprendre vous
n'êtes pas assez florentin femme était
originaire avoir rejoint collet a
nutshell c'est peut-être qu'à pul i la
cherche
bagdad à nous c'est aussi dans votre
langage
mais à zoom remettez le masque les sacs
fabrique si vous commencez à comprendre
non pas très bien il faut aller vite
fait un effort lucho s'est déjà montré à
votre femme au début du bal dans un
travesti romantique en pierrot il va
maintenant maintenant l'invité à danser
en arlequin harlequins c'est à dire le
travesti fabrizzi est lui parlera donc
croyants les a fabriquées bien c'est
fabrice du club lucho bien nous le dira
puis rando son premier travestis ou
alors c'est fabriqué le chandelier et
s'est collé à l'eau qu'elle aime mais
pour plus de sûreté admirait montpon
lucho revêt tout de même le travesti de
koléa non c'est à dire scaramouche et
recommence tout la scène en se faisant
passer pour coller à nos wii la wii
oui mr b geneviève elle commencera tels
que c'est elle ne sait pas dans quel
travail s'ils sont exacts il faut
montrer ses couleurs à la belle les
voici le camélia valides ou l'orchidée
coller à nos les fleurs de leur
corbeille
oui que lucho j'avoue que c'est
admirable je me rends alors le show
commence tout moi je ne suis plus qu'un
instrument
ben quoi tu n'approuve pas se plaindre à
la russe je préfère encore la force et
ou de la vérité la vérité lottiaux la
vérité est ce qu'on nous la donne à nous
la vérité il faut payer les gens dans
leur monnaie cela dit j'ai accepté de
jouer ce rôle je jouais l'essentiel la
zone sécu ne connaissent plus le
tourment du doute
[Musique]
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
hu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
puis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bah c'est pas lucho
oui c'est moi un bon goûter c'est fait
quel est sûre alors c'est miss et le
chandelier nom lui a prédit
oui mais relève thomas ce que monza
alors alors geneviève irréprochable tu
l'as vu ce son masque et moi je suis
toujours l'homme aux idées noires
je voudrais que tu vas te fait rien
c'est comique c'est que cette fois que
tu aux premières loges
tu latine et dans tes bras ce n'était
pas les tiens elle regarde ta bouche et
c'était celle de l'autre c'est enfin
qu'aucune lucho
avec moi comme moi et plus que moi
j'avoue que c'est une déception fabrique
et qui me dit après tout cas n'a pas
aussi envie de coller à non tiens lucho
tu l'aurais pas c'est le travesti de
coller à l'oscar nos choix inutile en
effet l'air bien sûr de toi mais qu'est
ce que tu as dit vous êtes resté à peine
quelques secondes à l'ensemble un elle
le mari a dit [ __ ] j'ai dit non alors
comme on peut tout savoir
elle m'a embrassé temps passe mais oui
comme ça pendant un mois oui c'est sur
la bouche oui
et tu tenais ce faire ça losc aurait
fait faillite si non pardon excusez moi
alors oui je veux la voir je peux lâcher
son masque
tous les ans il a fait de lui le masque
n'en a plus
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est toi mariner la viande
viens vous excellence
j'ai appelé marinella vous n'avez pas
entendu si alors pourquoi mon dieu je
voulais jouer un instant monde ce soir a
le droit de s'amuser un peu avec les
mains ce nom je ne m'attendais pas à ça
je vous fais mes excuses excellence
pourquoi aussi marine et là c'est le
même trop mystique mois on fait
peut-être le savez vous
non excellence je ne sais pas mais
souvent sans oublier
[Musique]
en fait rodino
excellence
vous contre moi vous aussi je vous ai
plus vu parce que jamais adressé la
parole
mais asus va beaucoup parler de lui et
je ne sais pas pourquoi je pensais que
vous vous seriez avec moi j'étais avec
vos excellences 3d vous cesser d'y être
je ne sais pas deux fois que vous
répondez je ne sais pas lorsque vous
savez pas ou ne l'a pourtant dit que
vous aviez revendre un mensonge
eh bien j'ai cessé d'être avec vous
quand j'ai vu que je me trompe est sur
votre compte en me croyais entonnait we
quand l'avez-vous vu je ne peux pas vous
le dire moi je peux quand j'ai embrassé
fabrice c'est à dire vous compte dans
son costume d'un requin comment vous
saviez que c'était moi vous voyez
pourquoi ce baiser alors on vous donnait
une leçon comme père gino vous avez
voulu vous jouez de moi je me suis jouer
d'où est ce mal veuillez me pardonner
excellence je ne suis pas très fier mais
vous voyez j'ai bien joué mon rôle
les amateurs de vérité sont mal à l'aise
sous les masques
oui je vous sais gré d'avoir arraché le
vôtre vous avez abrégé mans supplice car
le mensonge est pour moi un véritable
supplice pour moi aussi comptent
vraiment est-ce que je ne viens pas de
vous le prouver
si c'est juste alors fabrizzi le jeu me
mall de fabricom de koléa nord et
d'ailleurs c'était tunisie la zone
personne ne la lui aurait enlevé de la
tête et j'ai fini par lui mentir pour
qu'ils ne pensent plus que je lui ment
voilà la vérité excellent si vous saviez
la joie que vous me faites je le disais
bien la zone elle n'est pas comme les
autres avec elle nous allons être
heureux
nous donner vos excellences met à sonner
moi sommes tellement bien que tout ce
qu'il atteint matin ce baiser la
fabrique dit mais bien parce je ne vais
pas jouer plus mal que moi en le
recevant se montre investi en fin de
compte c'est vous qui l'avez reçu je
m'en excuse excellence ainsi vous vous
ne croyez
oui moi je crois c'est vrai vous avez
les yeux de quelqu'un qui croit c'est
bon la confiance quoi ajoutait une passé
violent
ne faut pas lui en vouloir mon dieu ils
ont menti oui je sors cave où je vais
pouvoir dire la vérité
mais oui sinon je vous l'avais
d'ailleurs dit oui je les vis tu mets
pas toutes à non non la vérité n'a
jamais aussi simple vous n'avez pas
remarqué souvent en effet avez vous
remarqué aussi que tout qu'on ne l'a pas
dit à haute voix
on n'est pas sûre d'elle bien dit l'
excellence dit là toute la vérité ne se
détaille pas les origines à dire c'est
difficile oui mais après on est si bien
bien voilà azzoun se tromper sur collet
a noué fabry 17 break
mais il ne se trompait pas lorsqu'il
disait qu'il y avait quelqu'un comment
quelqu'un vous voulez dire qu'il y a
tout de même un homme qui je pense est
oui je crois
vous croyez et tant que je n'ai pas du
tout un choix n'est ce pas je ne suis
pas absolument si bien dit le seul ans
et oui je ne connais pas le regarda son
je vous en prie vous mais oui c'est moi
parler mais j'ai parlé c'est vous quoi
c'est moi cet homme c'est vous c'est
drôle je les dis vous avez entendu
oui oui j'ai entendu face à saint just à
vous ne trouvez pas ça semble peut-être
juste mais c'est impossible c'est ce que
je me disais aussi mais vous voyez en
disant oh tu vois ta bio très possible
qui est allé vous m'étonnez des falaises
dans la tête mais où c'est certain a
perdu en temps de me répéter s'il y
avait quelqu'un lui fini par me dire s
il avait raison après tout il a plus
d'expérience que moi louis et c'est ce
soir que douce et éclairé grâce à ajoute
encore à ajouter 800 pages vous n'auriez
jamais embrassée pourquoi ne pas le dire
c'est en vous embrassant que j'ai
compris qu'elle on avait raison je vous
embrasse mais je ne savais pas si
c'était vous mais moi je le savais non
c'est impossible
n'importe qui mais pas moi n'importe
quel homme va dire vous aurais tu
embrasses à c'était lui alors moi je ne
crois pas vous voyez la zone n'a jamais
cessé de nous parler de votre charme de
vos mairies et c'est cool qui flottait
dans ma pensée tout naturellement mais
de là à vouloir comme soyeuse à moi il
dit pas une chose pareille ce n'est pas
moi qui l'a dit c'est lui faut
reconnaître qu'il a bien travaillé et
c'est vous qui l'a chargé de trouver cet
homme ne l'oublié pas c'est vrai
j'oubliais alors vous allez lui dire que
c'est vous jamais de la vie pour vous
avoir convaincu le très capable de s'en
convaincre lui même et qui sait nous
manquons gras que moi aussi une force de
conviction redouta redoutable ah oui non
je veux rassurer puisque cette fois ils
ne courent aucun risque
sa chance toujours d'un internaute
rassurer les
aucune autre quand unités ronde et lui
la sienne si vous pouvez non frôlé
l'esclandre à dunga a fait son masque à
mariner leur croyant que c'était john
bien il est hors de lui
ouf les journalistes n'ont rien vu oui
il est hors de lui il sait très joli de
vouloir sortir du doute mais tant qu on
y est dans le doute au moins on se tient
tranquille où est-il de la carotte
azumi cherche sa femme et comme elles
sont deux ce n'est pas facile alors ses
fabriques ya bien bien votre foi ont
organisé une petite promenade en barque
sur l'arno et chaud ce n'est pas
fabriqué dans la carotte
comment ce n'est pas fabriqué oui ma
femme vous m'améliore qu'attendez vous
pour donner le signal de lever les
basques avant ce n'est pas mal mais
pourquoi l'espagne moment l'outil oman
où ils guident pas devant vous donne à
carlotta veuillez m'excuser bien bien
bien je vous laisse avec une vérité qui
ne peut être entendu de tous
moi je retourne anemasse son faire alors
[Applaudissements]
tu as fais déjà du travail
moi oui toi j'ai vu ta femme à l état
encore avec toi oui mais ils vont être
investis n'était plus dans le mien et
sans masque ni elle ni moi et quand je
dis sans masque j'entends aussi sans
mensonge
elle savait que dans le costume de
fabrizzi c'était moi elle savait que
aulas car
elle a dit jouer le plan de la mer alors
quoi t'attendre assez pour se moquer de
nous comme doodle non ce n'est pas non
plus connu et je peut te rassurer à une
femme n'aura pas d'âme en mai elle en
voulait rien que l'assuré elle n'en aura
pas ah ben on ne peut pas ce que tu
l'aies décidé justement quels besoins
vêtu du parler de cet homme mais
j'aurais vu le tuf avec moi sur le
bateau
l'autre a toujours l'eau c'était une
idée fixe chez toi pour obsédés le te
dis qu'il y en avait que pour lui au
mettons une peuvent empêcher une femme
d'avoir de la sympathie pour un jeune
homme qui le méritent peut-être après
tout
en tout bien tout honneur ce sont leurs
parents je veux dire que jusque là il
n'y avait rien de man pouvait penser à
lui sans aucune intention coupable
c'était gentil les choses en rester là
110 cas présent à présent elle a couché
c'est ça je t'en prie surveille tes mots
il n'en est pas question
mais qui l'a mise dans un temps très
très pénibles et moi aussi
pour aussi est là cherchent un foyer à
se faire de toi une aile ça je ne ferai
pas son allié j'étais dit qu'elle
n'aurait pas demain mais tu dois donner
l'envié d'en avoir un et tu as créé ce
soir l'atmosphère qu'il fallait
ce bal c'est masquer ses bras zones dans
lesquelles elle passe et bien cette
amende qui lui a patiemment foncé dans
la tête
le premier homme qu elle embrassera tu
entends il se dirait c'est lui voilà
mais qu'est ce que tu racontes
mais personne ici là à l'ombre à ces
personnes je ne le fais pas dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
tu l'as vu huy qui a devancé toi et moi
mais je suis aussi pour l e mes fils
kolia l'idylle haut niveau
ni l'un ni l'autre deux chandeliers
cette petite française aurait-elle du
sample entraîneur ma mère du mois quel
personnage suis je te remercie parce que
c'est lui
l embrasser et vous embrasse personnage
retenir lucho
merci j'avais raison
[Applaudissements]
rassurez déchaîné oui pourquoi qu'il
avait là des voix embrassés pour le
rassurer
je vous ai entendu c'est le premier rôle
qu elle embrassera j'ai pensé c'est une
bonne idée
oui seulement il a cru que vous n'en
fassiez un autre et le palais sèche
pourrait après lui courait vite pourquoi
fait de lui dire que c'était bien lui
mais à quoi bon s'il ya une chose que
vous ne ferez jamais croire ses côtés
lui que j'ai embrassé essayer non
j'aurais l'air de me disculper il
trouvera ça encore plus douce puis
rallumer tous ces soupçons moi c'est
comique prévu qu'il que les faits bien
n'est ce pas raison sinon c puis soyons
francs nous savons qu'à présent il a
raison qu'il ya quelqu'un une fois jean
jacques baly non nous ne savons qu'ils
ne peuvent rien y avoir entre nous
are you mais lui il ne s'est passé nous
est persuadé que si elle nous met dans
une bonne situation
moi je sais ce qu'il me reste à faire
quoi donc c'est le doute qui rend fou et
la puissance à le dissiper qui rend
folle savoir de qui est une délivrance
personne ne peut les lui apporter cette
délivrance six mois comment si je vous
le dis vous ne comprendrez pas dit bien
en prenant qu'avant vous voulez vous
voyez vous ne prenez pas quand j'aurai
un amant il pour enfin respirer et moi
aussi mais c'est absurde si tu me marier
pas pour ça ah non mais tant pis j'irai
jusqu'au bout
vous ne le ferez pas ce soir même dans
ce bal
j'ai choisi la quelques à n'importe qui
il faut garder son masque je me moque
bien de savoir quel visage et là j'irai
jusqu'au bout comme ça je pourrais en
parler à zoug avec l'acteur la vérité je
voudrais c'est qu'il y aura plein doute
parce que tout est prêt excellence ne
m'appelez pas comme ça m'horripile
je viens
[Applaudissements]
tu te concentres toi m'arrive à la
marine et le reste
écoutez moi bien tous les deux je viens
d'arrêter un nouveau plan avec ma mère
elle a raison geneviève brouille les
cartes
mensonge baiser tout lui est permis pour
couvrir l'homme qu'elle aime mais cet
homme il est ici ce soir bien ici dans
ce palais sous son masque devient on
enlèvera pas les masques le seul masque
comment les bras ce sera le sien voilà
comment je pars appelé d'urgence en
suisse
pas un départ simuler un départ et elle
même mère et des genres est pas en train
de répondre le bruit l'avion est
commandé il aussi tout relâchement total
de la surveillance est bien entendu
marinella ayant occupe toi de lucho et
lucho de toi comme vous avez commencé de
le faire unico il faut que geneviève se
sente en liberté ainsi elle aura une
tentation faire monter son amant dans sa
chambre qu'est ce que tu vas dire
qu'elle le fera pas dans l'optimisme
comme d'habitude vers soit tranquille
elle ne le fera et pas tout sera là dans
l'ombre et cela surprendra au moment
voulu
et c'est fini c'est ce soir lucho
content ce soir et pas un autre que tu
dois savoir qui est son amant bon comme
le ce sera enfermée voici pour toi
c'est la clé de sa chambre quand la pas
d'objection
et maintenant aller danser
[Musique]
à ce effet rien maintenant que je vais
quitter ce travesti ma mère j'aimerais
bien savoir quel personnage suis-je
ah oui attendait arnaud art 9
oui quatre français l'école des femmes
école des femmes connaît pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soc 5 heures elle dépasse les bornes
les autres - fut dans les mots robe
qu'elle devrait faire ça ailleurs
celle ci s'est emballé dans sa chambre
son téléphone décroché ses domestiques
revoyez c'est tout le ciel mais pas un
écriteau sur sa porte
prière de ne pas déranger le flou c'est
un scandale
les murs de ce palais n'est jamais
pareil du tout cas quoi bien madame la
princesse a dit le fils d'un petit jeu
mais même le prince est bien à marine
elle a enfin toi au moins tu avais envie
j'ai trouvé les semaines s'est montrée
tarik et l'eau c'est pourquoi street art
été relevés ton service garde ton
cachette dormir les nerfs excellence
j'avais danser toute la nuit avec les
galants de la princesse geneviève pour
finalement me retrouver dans ma chambre
seul vous comprenez excellent où il a
géré oui je comprends injuste soir au
lucho ne pouvait pas venir te rendre
visé et oui je l' ai attendu en vain je
savais que lui était de service mais je
ne pensais pas que ça durerait aussi
longtemps encore mais où est-il dans les
jardins sous les fenêtres de la
princesse pourquoi ce ses fenêtres à
tous voudraient tout de même pas ce soit
dans sa chanson bien sûr pas dans mon
plan
la belle s'est bien l'enfermer mais l'a
laissé la clé dans la serrure impossible
à lucho d'entrée de la surprendre comme
prévu il est donc allé se poster dans
les arbres un surveillant la porte
fenêtre de sa chambre seule issue par où
l'oiseau peut s'envoler sans être vu et
il ne s'est pas encore envolé pas encore
depuis ce matin 2
je ne sais pas qui nous avons affaire
mais c'est sûrement lui tire dessus
mais deux textes signés aux sahraouis
tout de même j'ai pas de lucho a lui
aussi jeté à corps vous malgré le client
que giuseppe lui apporter ce matin est
mort de faire ça il avait sifflé qu'il a
demandé qu'on lui apporte à manger pour
deux pour deux oui hélas tous les maux
est l'outil on a retrouvé sur le client
que des pleins et des bouteilles vides
le pauvre garçon excellence je ne
pourrais pas le voir lucho
à quoi bon tous zappelli encore de le
voir à l'instant que ces fonds oui oui
enfin il ne devrait pas être loin le
playon était toujours la même place mais
oui dit il
il m'avait prévenu si vous ne me voyez
pas giuseppe c'est que je me dégourdir
un peu les jambes sans perdre de vue les
fenêtres de la princesse ça on peut lui
faire confiance
le voilà champion c'est flou c'est vous
pourquoi c'est vous parce que savais pas
ce que je vous vois enfin à bon faut
m'excuser je suis un peu fatigué huawei
mon petit nom petit peu il tombe de
sommeil asseyez-vous la niacine ici si
ce n'est pas un client
asseyez vous voyez bien que je ne vous
saute pas dessus en criant classe
maintenant savez c'est l'essentiel
quand je te vide mon petit réduit quoi
qu'est ce que vous devinez
c'était à familier dazu n'est ce pas
celui qu on est à cent lieues de pouvoir
soupçonné vous prononcer son nom
atterré comme un mari trompé dit à son
meilleur ami thomas personne et vous qui
ne monte jamais vous serez prêt à le
faire pour le ter selon tellement vous
êtes déclaré tom trompe non en phase iib
d'un acteur notait n'y avait personne
dans la chambre de la princesse
geneviève personnes permettez moi de
vous présenter mes respects l'excellence
et de bons mercier m'ont remercié et de
quoi grands dieux mais de tout du bal
des masques du voyage des volumes des
nouvelles consignes du conte lucho sous
mes fenêtres
autant d'idées que l'on vous doit
l'excellent est ce que le rapport du cor
de lucho vous satisfait son horreur du
mensonge économie après 14 heures de
guerre il me fit sortir de ma chambre
seul il a aussitôt fouillé mais
appartement de fond en comble il ne
pourra pas vous dire que je cachais un
homme chez moi et tous les domestiques
postés dans les couloirs ne vous en
dirons pas davantage puisqu'il n'y avait
personne
et pourtant deux danseurs ont quitté le
bal en même temps que moi pour me
permettre vous voyez de rester dans ma
chambre seule avec mes rêves je devrais
vous faire des excuses et vous féliciter
pour une vertu aussi injustement
soupçonné mais je suis femme on sea
princess est depuis plus longtemps que
vous hélas alors permettez moi de vous
dire à mon tour une chose votre vertu je
n'y crois pas la vertu est une auteure
qui peut tromper l'amour on a une qui ne
trompe pas aujourd'hui princesse vous
respirez l'amour vous nous avez tous où
les je vous félicite y compris ce pauvre
lucho
on ce n'est pas un reproche mouture 2
minutes de sommeil sur son pliant ce
n'est pas un crime mais pendant ce
torero l'oiseau symbole vous avez gagné
la première manche mais moi je vous dis
à la prochaine excellence mais cette
fois de vous donnez pas tant de mal
lorsqu'un homme et une femme ont envie
de s'appartenir aucune puissance au
monde ni la florence ne peut les en
empêcher vous devriez le savoir
excellence
au volet tu sais
un score marinella oui excellence
embrassez moi
excusez moi je ne peux pas vous méprisez
au nom il c'est de revoir leur tête
je les avais si bien oublié tout ce pour
quoi vous méprise règes moi aussi je
vous désirez et bien avant le bal le
jour du mariage
oui j'ai même été jaloux la zone pour la
première fois oui je me souviens mais
vous ne m'auriez jamais rien dit la
vraie coupable c'est bien moi fallait
non c'est moi on est pas là mais la zone
je suis sa femme ces femmes toujours
trompés tandis que moi mettons que nous
soyons coupables tous les mais je ne
voudrais pas que vous m'abandonner à moi
seul je me sens plutôt perdu
j'étais si peu préparés à tous ces
événements il ya huit jours je l'avais
même pas encore de marie et aujourd'hui
je vous abandonne pas mais je suis aussi
perdus que vous et aussi peu préparée
moi qui n'ai jamais trompé qui que ce
soit au monde voilà que j'ai trompé
quelqu'un et qui a zone asie où une
petite incroyable d'ailleurs c'est
simple je ne crois pas que je suis comme
vous je ne le crois pas nous n'étions
fait ni l'un ni l'autre pour ce qui nous
arrive ça non dire qu'il y en a
tellement qui nage dans ces situations
comme poisson dans l'eau il fallut que
ça tombe sur nous et pourtant je veux
dire une chose nous sommes juré veut
nous dire toujours la vérité n'est ce
pas oui je ne regrette rien
moi non plus et ce qui est inouï
alors c'est vrai tu es sur wii
honteux mais heureux
répète je suis honteux je suis heureux
j'ai beau me dire toi trompé ajoute je
suis heureux quand même c'est à n'y rien
comprendre
c'est très curieux et d'un complexe
rien à voir avec ce que racontent les
romans et les pieds à dori je pense être
constamment à lui je croyais qu'il me
serait impossible d'effleurer jamais un
seul d'été cheveux mais dès que j'ai été
touché basu une fille je n'y ai plus
pensé moi c'est pareil je ne pensais
qu'elle lui aussi à lui me torture ans
par sa jalousie est dans tes bras fille
j'ai enfin pu chasser cet hymne est
maintenant là je te regarde je sais ce
que nous avons fait mais pas un instant
je ne pense que je me trompe moi non
plus je vais même plus loin je pense que
c'est lui qui me trompe pas ce que tout
cela n'est pas extraordinaire si mon
amour extraordinaire ça va anvers toutes
les idées que j'avais sur la question
malheureusement nous ne pouvons pas
aller lui expliquer tout ça et dans
quelques minutes il va être là dans
quelques minutes déjà
et vous savez ce qu'il va faire en
arrivant je ne sais plus très bien non
vous interrogez mon
pourquoi moi toujours parce que c'est
vous qui était chargé de me surveiller
ses vous à qui il a remis la clé de ma
chambre c'est vous qui devez savoir ce
soir et pas un autre qui était mon amour
or pourra dire qu'il ya mis du sien
nous allons devoir faire la chose dont
nous avons eu plusieurs heures m'ont
menti mentir et azzoun j'aurais
peut-être plus de facilités qu on dit
qu'une femme qui ment par amour n'a
jamais l'impression de lentilles mais
vous me lucho qui avait une telle
répugnance pour le mensonge quand je me
demande si on ne ferait pas mieux de lui
dire la vérité à qui la vérité vous êtes
devenue folle chez vous je vous en prie
ne porterait pas ce coup je suis là pour
le défendre je les ai toujours fait ce
n'est pas aujourd'hui que je vais
l'abandonner aujourd'hui mon amour quoi
aujourd'hui
alarmante il va vous demander qui était
mon amour qu est ce que vous allez me
répondre
voyons qu'est ce que je vais lui
répondre bien personne non vous preniez
pas que c'est mieux étant déjà réfléchi
personnes mais alors pourquoi
l'aurais-je laisser croire qu'il y avait
quelques oui pourquoi
pour les données ne sont tout simplement
voilà pour lui donner une leçon mines me
torture à pleigne m est rappelé comme
une favorite des comics américains
allaient venir très important vous avez
raison personne est en outre hiller oui
ça qu'on veut sauf au cul c'est vilain
tromper leiria mais après il faut mentir
mais vous vous trouvez tout ça c'est moi
qu'il dirait mais vous voulu répondre et
personnes
et après après c'est tout c'est quand
même une bonne nouvelle
l'événement youtube et même mauvaise il
aurait été mis là commenté alan penser
au plaisir qu'il aura là commenté bonne
non rassurez-vous de mon côté tout ira
bien
c'est vous qui m'a inquiété que cette
idée seulement pu vous effleurez quelle
idée d'aller lui dire la vérité
observez-vous des prodiges de
dissimulation me promettez moi que vous
trahirais oui mon fou faut que je suis
mais au premier regard on va le voir cet
écrit sur notre visage ça éclate dans
vos yeux sont perdus et nous aide parce
que c'est vous mais lui le croira et
puis tout ce que raconte le livre n'est
pas faux les inquiets qui se torture
quand il n'y a rien ont paraît-il une
soudaine sérénité qu'on la change est
arrivé s'il me soupçonne moi c'est un
peu ça il faut tout prévoir thiboust
comment ils vous regardent comme ça au
fond des yeux c'est lucho n'est ce pas
alors à vous c'est lui d'une saga nous
sommes perdus cette fois jeudi comme
dans un lit parce que c'est toi c'est
alors que je serai le plus sûr de moi tu
me jure je te le jure
tu ne parlera pas jamais sous les pires
menaces à la torture je ne parlerai pas
la lumière de celle ville qu'est ce que
nous allons solaire devrait dire à chaud
c'est vrai quoi est ce que c'est vrai et
ce qui est vrai mais ce que m'a dit ma
mère
qu'est ce que tu as dit qu'elle n'était
rien arrivé oui c'est vrai c'est vrai
oui elle n'a pas la main non il n'y
avait personne personne je le savais oui
je le savais à mon pauvre loupiots de
l'imaginer que je me ronger les sangs à
me demander si c'était déjà que pierre
ou paul et bien non pour la première
fois j'y voyais clair
je me suis dit c'est ta faute tu ta
jalousie elle a voulu tout donner une
bonne petite leçon voilà tout un lucho
ne nous sommes pas qu'aucune annonce n'a
pas l'air sûre de toi si si elle ne
croyait bien partie oui le noeud se
méfier pas nous non et s'il y avait eu
quelqu'un à ce bal
il aurait été à ce bal à coup sûr oui
telle aurait attiré dans sa chambre oui
mais alors tu peux pas avoir du tout
mais que veux tu as qu'est ce qui touche
fun au québec c'est oui je sais ma mère
va raconter
14h02 pire mais c'est fini alors on n'y
pense plus et rien pleuré avec moi
mary lou johri voyons non c'est
impossible c'est impossible en effet
encore je ne pouvais pas c'est inutile
je ne pourrais pas qu'est-ce que tu ne
pourras pas cet ajout est n'avait pas
prévu ta joie
vous n'imaginez tout de même pas que
j'allais sangloter ça je ne supporte pas
ta joue avec mes dettes plus bas cet ami
envier tétouan - mais pourquoi ne
supporte pas ma joie pourquoi ne la
partagent tu fais comme d'habitude parce
que je suis un sale deux oiseaux qu'est
ce que tu as menti oui j'étais menti
mais c'est fini depuis tu le vois bien
je ne peux plus en danger ne vient nous
pourquoi demander pardon à geneviève
bon tu vas tu expliquer oui ou non bon
tu m'as menti ya l'homme
oui bien un homme c'est qu'on me regarde
le regarde le bien c'est le petit [ __ ]
quai devant toi mais quel petit [ __ ]
celui là celui là toi oui moi moi
l'autre jour voilà me avec un grand à
ces mois au jeu les speed mais vous
comme moi comme tout cette histoire
je ne crois pas tu ne vas pas me faire
ce coup là c'est assez terrible de
parler tout était vrai col et alleo
fabrizzi étaient bien les chandeliers
chandelier caché bien la nomme cet homme
c'était moi c'était toi oui bon
admettons
il ne croit pas ah non je ne crois pas
on remarque que je ne demande qu'un
croire voyons tu m'avais bien dit hier
soir ce sera le premier homme qu elle
embrassera non oui c'est mon premier
roman qu'elle avait embrassé c'était moi
tu n'avais pas arrêté de parler de moi
la pensée as soon as raison je suis
attiré par un homme c'est comme c'est
lui voilà je ne pouvais pas le dire tout
de suite c'est tellement suffocant
métaux à ma place un zonage était si sûr
de moi oui oui c'est pourquoi tu me
garantissait qu'elle n'aurait pas demain
et oui mais mon pauvre lottiaux
mais tu as dû être malheureux comme les
pierres si tout ce que tu trouves a dit
souhaité toi mais c'est merveilleux
c'est merveilleux bah oui c'est comme
une preuve de plus qu'elle-même résoudre
c'est moi c'est moi eh ben c'est toi
c'est toutefois présent c'est ignoble de
sa part mais toi tu n'y es pour rien et
moi qui m'attendais à je ne sais quel
rastaquouère mais si c'est toi tu avais
raison que fut sauvée tu t'es sauvé hier
mais pas aujourd'hui
mais pourquoi que si le vase et de
plaisanteries hier et aujourd'hui la
nuit n'a pas fait alors il n'a rien
compris à zoug te répète que je suis un
petit salon un vrai petit [ __ ] mais
pourquoi parce que ma femme parce que ma
femme a eu envie de coucher avec toi
non parce que moi j'ai couché avec elle
faut que tu me fasses tri qu'est ce que
tu dis la vérité
tu as dû comment faut-il te le dire
quand tu entends une fois que tu as beau
tourner évidemment
regarde moi mais c'est vrai qu'il a fait
il l'a fait mais bien forme toi que je
puisse te casser la figure
non il ne se déforme pas possible ils
eurent un petit canard vibrant
youtube
question vous êtes arrivé à ça tu peux
le dire
thonon plus tu n'arrives pas réalisé non
tant que tu es là quand elle sa vie mais
je expliquer ma commande c'est arrivé je
veux savoir t'énerve pas comment ça
arrive et nous allons devoir tous les
deux ensemble comme nous l'avons fait
rappelle toi les autres froyo et les
autres fois un roman sans vous emballez
comment on ne comprendra jamais rien moi
aussi je veux comprendre ces montants là
sauf moi aussi je comprends ce prix
bambins t'énerve pas non plus parce
qu'enfin geneviève m'attirait c'est
entendu mais c'était normal va commencer
de leurs maris qudsiya zone tout de même
je me suis toujours efforcé de regarder
des femmes avec les même mieux que toi
ce n'est pas nouveau mais ce n'était pas
une raison pour faire ce que j'ai fait
il me semble
comment cette justice avec les autres
dit il jamais eu la moindre chose
équivoque oui avec les autres mais je me
rappelle à présent tu m'avais dit avec
geneviève je sens enfin l'amour c'est
juste de voix je ne me trompais premier
mais oui mais oui nous aurions dû nous
méfier il est fier mais un jeune qui
aurait pu prévoir une chose paraît les
bambins et argué roulant alors
expliquez-moi comment
au lieu de se lamenter sur son sort
c'est quand elle a décidé de prendre un
amant
il m'a dit je suis à bout de temps que
je n'aurais pas d'âme en azote me
torture à je vais en prendre à ce soir
même dans ce bal n'importe qui et
j'avoue qu'elle m'a impressionné ça
n'aurait pas questionner toi oui mais
alors que sunu répondu non vous ne ferez
jamais ça donc très bien et ensuite
ensuite attend à wingene embrasser
tu l'a embrassée bah oui tu vois je le
reconnais comprend pas non plus pourquoi
ce baiser
peux tu me le diras zone pourquoi mais
pourquoi bon dieu a non non ça ne peut
pas je te garantis que ce jeu vous avez
vu tous les deux que vous avez vous ai
vue oui quand tu es venu nous annoncer
que tu pars tu es tu sais n'était pas
marinelak j'embrassais set et elle ne
voulait pas le dit non non je ne pouvais
pas à moins d'être le dernier des mufles
d'ailleurs tout de même pas laisser
ouvrir la bouche tu m'a collé d'autorité
la clé de sa chambre dans les mains tu
m'as fait relâcher tout surveillance tu
m'a ordonné d'aller la rejoindre chez
elle c'est moi qui vous ai fait coucher
ensemble faut reconnaître que tu t'es
conduit d'une façon insensée
m'abandonner dans un moment pareil
moi j'avais envie de cliquer à sous ne
va pas non aller danser ma main si
j'avais su que c'était tel jeu je vous
ai fait danser tous les deux une de ses
fans ce dont vous auriez gardé le
souvenir achetant près un quart de notre
calme si tu ne peux pas te minutes il es
mois encore attends je fais de
comprendre tout ce dont elle continue
jean est au calme donc je les embrasse
mais brive et il était encore question
de reviens je t'en donne ma parole
d'ailleurs il me quittes pour danser
avec d'autres masques et qui collait est
brisée à cela et cela observe elle se
montre coquette avec les deux jeux elle
va vraiment se choisir un amant enfin ce
n'est pas toi ouf je préfère encore être
cocus avec la zone comme d'habitude que
le qualifier je te retrouve enfin tant
elle quitte le bad les deux masques
aussi je bondis à sa chambre la clé je
ne peux pas ouvrir
elle avait laissé la sienne dans la
serrure je dégringole dans les jardins
je me poste sous ses fenêtres je
n'imagine dans les bras d'un de ces
coquins agrola dieu oui un homme est là
qui la tient dans ses bras je les
embrasse lui aussi web est ce que je
suis c'est toi attend pas encore je
frappe à sa porte fenêtre la douve elle
m'ouvre sans aucun dégât je fume sa
chambre de fond en comble boudoir salle
de bains placard penderie personnes
tuant pas une personne n'était pas
magnifique
oui oh comme je connais la suite du
congrès
n'empêche que j'ai respiré bon alors
pourquoi n'es tu pas ressorti pourquoi
opter temps insipide dans ma
précipitation je m'étais un peu écorché
la main elle a pu me faire un petit
pansement et voilà pas du tout on
n'imagine pas comment ces choses
arrivent il faut vraiment y avoir pensé
ben ali alors ça me restait quelques
instants bavarder les aimablement du
moment que le besoin avait dû de baba et
sur quoi sur toi parce que je t'assure
zoom que malgré ce baiser nous n'avions
aucune intention coupable et nous
cherchons sincèrement tous les deux
ensemble le moyen de guérir de me guérir
mais de quoi me porte très bien de ta
jalousie
j'avais beau proposer d'autres remettre
nous et n'en revenaient toujours au même
prendre un amant
c'était une idée fixe chez toi
maintenant c'était chez elle et j'ai
compris que personne au monde pas même
moi ni pour l en empêcher
oui alors en somme si je comprends bien
c'est pour l'empêcher de prendre un
amant que tu es devenu le sien quoi
thullier brutalement mais au fond ça
j'ai pensé à toi merci je me suis dit
entre deux premiers aventuriers venus et
moi hassoun n'hésiterait pas elle me
choisir voila voila c'est moi qui l'ait
choisie non je ne dis pas ça mais c'est
pour expliquer comment les choses se
sont passées et jusqu'à présent mon dieu
est expirée le public
elle s'explique si elle s'explique enfin
jusque là puisqu'elle aura partir de là
tu comprends plus rien c'est la nuit la
nuit noire
oui bon alors écoute c'est la nuit comme
tu dis que la vertu la garde pour toi
moi ça me suffit comme ça alors as tu ne
vas pas me laisser en plan représente
c'est trop commode
tu me fais parler tu exiges de tout
savoir et puis stop au moment le plus
important puisque je vote en fait grâce
à l'aura sous moi j'ai toujours écouté
tes confidences alors fait comme moi tu
vas voir c'est très bizarre hein je
raisonne tu m'as demandé en plaisantant
si je pourrais te tromper avec une de
tes femmes je ne sais plus laquelle il
n'y avait jamais pensé mais c'est toi
qui m'a fait réfléchir et je t'ai
répondu très sincèrement que non mais
que j'en avais aucun mérite parce que je
ne pourrais pas une impossibilité
physique même si l'amitié ne me retenait
pas même à l'extrême bord d'un vertige
imprévu il serait là me disais-je et il
serait là implacablement traîneau baiser
et nos étreintes bien tu n'y étais pas à
zhouqu
c'est merveilleux qui n'y étaient pas
et maintenant j'y suis
[Musique]
tu les as juste grâce à moi tu n'es plus
connus mais qu'est ce que vous lui a
sauvé parce que tu penses maintenant
pour moi c'est fini
qu'est-ce qui est finie geneviève
j'étais sûr pourtant qu'il ya une heure
encore je n'aurais jamais cru tu peux
être que je te remercie que je te les
corps non mais tu crois que coller à nos
fabrizzi serait venu te raconter ce
qu'ils avaient fait eux et comment et
qu'ils se seraient effacés comme je vais
le faire moi
je te demande pardon pour la gifle
mais au fond le tout est de ma faute
j'étais tellement mêlée à mes amours ça
devait arriver un jour ou l'autre avec
une femme ou l'eau pour j'aurais préféré
que ce soit avec les autres c'était des
garçons
avec celle-ci ça ne pouvait arriver
qu'avec celle ci ben oui elle est bien
un lucho
oui elle est bien
tu ne gardes ce oui c'est elle qui se
joue tiens ta tête à temps joseph est ce
que tu veux faire la voir tout de suite
pourquoi joseph est un foyer la
princesse je deviens que de descendre
immédiatement je vous prie ne va pas me
dire que tu sait tous que mettre des
gants mais tu es fou je te défend lui
dire allemand de ce que je t'ai dit tu
me des twists des formes quitte à
délivrer décollé à le fabriquer et
autres et surtout du doute du terrible
doute mois en échange je ne te demande
qu'une chose son silence mais puisque je
sais qu'elle n'a pas elle doit pas
savoir que je les trahisse boireau du
coup tu veux la paire pour la garder
longtemps contre moi j'ai donné le
meilleur moyen de la garder en lui
répétant toutefois tu es le meilleur
moyen de la faire alors choisi et vic ou
non veux tu que je fasse reims au
courage qu'il m'a fallu pour te parler
ça te donnera suite de terre son
excellence la princesse en excellence
oui bon alors qu'est-ce que je ne sais
rien bon je sais tout je ne sais rien
j'étais juste dit qu'il n'y avait
personne
bon alors il faut doit avoir l'air
content très près je vais quand même pas
lui demander pardon si là où vas tu
restes là hop une honte et un volcan
attendent ses côtés mieux je ne sais pas
non plus voilà oui
e
bon bien finalement je te laisse ou non
mais oui après tout reste
on est bien de faire votre petit rapport
est un petit rapport aux le ballet
terminé à zoug fini les masses que vous
ne voulez pas aucun des trois n'est dupe
vous avez tendu un piège votre ami l'a
exécuté mais c'est vous deux qui avaient
été pris c'est vrai ça oui ma présence
n'est vraiment pas nécessaire si content
après le rôle que vous avez joué cette
nuit elle est bien entendu mais ce n'est
pas moi qui ai demandé au fonds de jouer
ah oui mais oui c'est moi j'étais bien
inspiré
j'espère que suivant sa noble habitude
s'est pas dit la vérité
oui oui oui oui oui il a fallu qu'il a
alors vous savez maintenant qui était
mon ami oui
je sais tout voilà un fantôme un fantôme
l'image te plaît lucho un fantôme
c'est joli un fantôme on me vous êtes le
premier à en rire ça me fait plaisir à
zone
je m'en vais mais reste leur ne fait pas
le fantôme les amuse toi ton rapport
était un peu succinct et pas drôle mais
la princesse va nous donner beaucoup
plus de détails les plus amusants mais
pas pressé vous avez pourtant refusé de
procéder odieux envers moi aujourd'hui
je me sens incline à l'indulgence et je
vous pardonne aux battues voix lucho
elle me pardonne
tout m'arrive aujourd'hui moi vous aviez
décidé que je serais un fidèle comme les
autres femmes personne au monde n'aurait
peut vous enlever cette idée de la tête
mais notre grande et surtout pas lui
alors je me suis dit si tu vis si
florence lui affirme qu'il a eu à y
croire at-il flou à florence
oui mais voilà comment florence la firme
bretelles parce que le bruit de ma
fidélité si répandu azzoun grâce à koné
à nolhac abrite encore eu tous les deux
on fera via n'importe cette nuit tous
les deux ont été giflés à huy salut
compte ne pas vous le dire il ne le
savait pas mais pour ces dommages
d'alluré fait plaisir par contre si j'ai
oublié vos lubies
je ne peux pas pardonner au nom au
pourquoi le pauvre garçon mais là c'est
injuste je le sais il a fait qu'exécuter
vos ordres
mais c'est ainsi c'est à lui que genre
quand je les ai vus prendre le guet dans
le jardin quand je me suis mise à lui
elle à le haïr aura compté moi ça c'est
très intéressant
geffray lui dire de rentrer dans ma
chambre
entrée contre fouillé et constater qu'il
n'y a pas dans tron que vous dans cette
chose pourquoi ne l'avez vous pas faire
non seulement je reste sur son pliant et
dieu qui n'est pas saine
si vous l'aviez vu la zone au clair de
lune
c'est ridicule
sadr est tordant mairie lucho riz avec
nous prends ça avec ben ali mais aussi
vous m'aviez tous misé dans un tel état
d'exaspération
colom qui à ce moment là serait entré
dans ma chambre je m'entendais bien
heureusement
et bien je vous jure que cet homme je
leur ai accueillis de bonne grâce à ce
que vous pourriez pas qui c'est tout cet
homme il sait que vous l'avez accueillir
il sait que c'était moi et qui le lui a
dit moi moi
[Musique]
npcil pour une fois que nous avions une
femme fidèle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui marine et la voilà huit jours que la
face à john games a disparue voilà du
jour que je me démène pour la retrouver
et je retrouverai et je la remettrai
dans ce palais du talus vivre aux
séquestrés j'ai juré qu'ils resteraient
princesse à zone et elle le reste
moi je n'ai rien contre excellence mais
trois marques innovent avec surprise
c'est que personne ici à l'air pressé de
l'avoir en devenir chacun boude dans son
coin à zoug ou de lucho lucho de buddh
et moi alors moi je suis debout des
parts ou non de ce passe-t-il tu le sais
alors dis le moi est d'abord la nuit du
bal je ne me trompais pas il y avait
bien un homme dans sa chambre n'est ce
pas oui excellence et hassoun lassus oui
c'est lens et ne veux pas en parler non
excellent pourquoi alors que d'habitude
il ne tarit pas de commentaires sur ses
infortunes 1
je n'en sais rien excellence mais il
ignore le nom de cet homme non
excellence comment il le sait oui là je
ne comprend plus qui a pu lui dire
pareil nous non pas elle mais lui
excellence lucho lucho mais outre on
nous a certifié qu'il n'y avait personne
dans la champ de la france il mentait
lothion mentir oui mais comme il ne peut
pas mentir longtemps il a fini par tout
à fait aux prestations menée par dire
qu'il était innocent ce violon tout le
monde sauf moi et qui était ce mais lui
excellence où l'excellence n'est pas
compris oui qui lui
lucho lucho c'est logique et terrasson
de la brassens mais il était dans les
genres d'heures non non dans sa chambre
excellence mais pour la surveiller par
autre chose
au début oui excellence mais après après
il n'a trompé excellence
qui précède viège excellence une
nouvelle donne à carlotta aussi pourquoi
je sais pas quand tu es dans les jardins
touzet pécout dans les jardins baisse de
là pourquoi je vous ai pu compter dans
les jardins c'est ce que je vous
demanderai de la carlotta est adéquat en
prix barré tout cela est fait parler un
pénis excellence cachés dans un petit
hôtel sordide non excellence est très en
vue à l'hôtel danieli alors pourquoi
tant mais huit jours pour la retrouver
parce que ces messieurs le détective
avec la même idée que votre excellence
c'est à dire
il cherchait la princesse incognito dans
tous les petits hôtels de la péninsule
sépare les journaux qui l'ont appris
monétaire avec qui il était pardon avec
10 et l excellence
mais elle voit beaucoup de monde elle
obtient un très grand succès auprès de
qui de tout le monde s'élance
tu vois votre excellence ne peut pas en
être surprise ses épouses ont toujours
beaucoup de succès à zone
ce scandale a assez duré ah oui une
voiture est prête à partir pour gagner
je vous conseille d'aller chercher la
princesse vous même et ne laisser ce
soin aperçoit à sony faut que tu y
ailles immédiatement bien mettez nous
d'abord avoir un entretien avec lucho
avec moi oui bon alors partez tous les
deux pour venise vous expliquerai dans
la voiture mais pour une fois zone mon
chéri pensez un peu à votre mère j'ai
une grande soif de fidélité au venin
tous ces jours ci je n'ai pas pu
supporter et à vue j'espère que tous
leurs a compris très bien zone de mon
côté m'aurait été très pénible de te
voir et je te sais gré d'avoir évité
personne ne t'empêche est partie
remarque si tu aurais pu supposer que
c'était pour aller la rejoindre
j'ai beaucoup réfléchi sous l'aiguillon
d'une crise comme celle-ci on réfléchit
plus en huit jours que pendant une vie
entière et qu'il dit tu quand tu m'as à
vous et à rhizome j'ai eu envie de te
tuer j'ai pensé il a fait ça bon mais
pourquoi l'at il fait pourquoi l'at il
dit les casters et la vie continue à
huit jours que je me dis la même chose
saisons maintenant
mais j'avais tort ce raisonnement est
honteux c'est toi qui était dans le vrai
en parlant était admirable de courage et
de loyauté
sur le moment il m'a fallu huit jours
pour en convenir
et ce n'est qu'aujourd'hui que je te
tire un coup de chapeau
tu vas peut-être un peu trop loin on tue
mes supérieurs tu le sais et geneviève
le sait aussi je le lui ai assez dit et
puis le reste est dans une circonstance
particulièrement difficile mais sous son
influence je suis capable mais aussi
d'acte d'une haute portée
c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui lucho je te
dis épouse leurs épouses et qui ne
viennent je divorce aurait eu l'habitude
et cette fois c'est toi qui te mariera
puis à ses attendus
je suis très ému à zoug que tu puisses
avoir une idée pas y'a pas ce que je
t'ai fait c'est bien parce que tu l'as
fait que je peux avoir cette idée mais
si c'est avec toi qu'elle peut être
heureuse et pas avec moi épouse une
nature merveilleuse a sonné mais quoi
les sites web it peut être une nature
merveilleuse pendant quelques instants
de pas trop longtemps
enfin donc tu sais quelle est cette
femme que tu me demandes d'épouser la
mienne oui la tienne tu l'oubliés moi je
ne pourrai jamais l'oublier tu seras là
entre nous non il a dit je n'y étais pas
tu n'y étais pas donc tu ne savais rien
maintenant que tu sais tu seras à bachy
solétanche pour toi tu débrouillera on
devenir son amant tu n'as pas eu autant
de scrupules comprends moi bien si grâce
à moi cette nuit un grand amour a
commencé je peux peut-être de faire une
raison et qui sait un jour être fiers de
vous deux mais une trahison crapuleuses
une coucherie d'un soir un coût de 100
ha non non non ça fume du portrait
jamais l'aurait poussée
tout est brusquement trop beau si tu dis
que tout est trop go way maintenant vos
marques en tant qu'homme fumeurs
quand tu perds ou gino je viens voir mon
mari voulez vous nous laissez s'il vous
plaît ah bon à vos ordres excellence lui
prévient la mer naturellement
vous êtes bien sûr que c'est à moi que
vous voulez parler aux oiseaux j'en suis
sûr
et je retourne chez mes parents pourquoi
ce crochet
oui
vous vous demandez pardon d'abord et
ensuite et ensuite pour vous dire que je
suis très malheureuse l'avez-vous fait
de moi comment ce que je veux moi
j'étais libre à petit jeune fille de
province fait pour épouser un brave
bourgeois de chez elle et bien lui faire
son ménage et ses enfants n'attendez pas
le prince charmant
il est arrivé voilà où j'en suis os jeté
en plus jeunes viennent
mais qu'est ce qui vous arrive
comment ce qui m'arrive vous ne le savez
pas non je vous sais trop bien oui oui
et oui la voix des victimes j'ai reconnu
cet officiel en coupe ne vous respecte
mais moise moi non consolez-vous tout ça
est oublié
oubliez vous pouvez oublier voix zoom se
traîner d'heure en heure en se disant tu
as trop béton marie toi tu ne vous le
dit pas avec quelle rapidité après huit
jours à compter du jours à peine répond
et avec qui non mais je le sais alors ne
le dit pas avec ça me fait pas peur de
venir avec son grand son seul ami
oiseaux dites moi que cet enfer ne va
pas durer et non je ne viendrai pas je
vais me faire n'importe quoi même
reprendre neuf ans je vous en prie je le
vire calmez vous
j'ai eu un grand corps celui de vous
traiter comme mes fans précédente
et savez vous qui est responsable de ce
qui nous est arrivé les vous ni moi mais
elle vaut autre sphère oui elles m'ont
fait du mal jadis le contenu
oui j'ai changé
si ce genre d'épreuve ne vous rendez pas
meilleure à 'conserver' et l
oui moi aussi je me sens meilleur réseau
pendant ces bijoux que j'ai fait une
découverte laquelle je suis une femme
fidèle
ah oui j'étais entourée d'hommes je ne
faisais rien pour les écarter au contrat
je voulais me prouver
eh bien je n'ai jamais eu la plus légère
tentation la preuve était folle cazouls
j'étais bien une femme fidèle mais j'en
suis sûr à ses travers si tout était à
recommencer il n'arriverait jamais rien
car geneviève moi je ne suis plus jaloux
jalouse ou si vous pouviez dire vrai
mais je dis vrai et je peux vous en
donner le prg avec l'attendent
j'accepte lucho comment vous acceptez
lucci oui je vous voulez dire qu'il peut
devenir votre mari mari pourquoi mon
mari mais après ce qui s'est passé entre
vous vous êtes fois sam hd pour un homme
avec qui je vous ai trop fait souvent
jamais vous m'entendez
pardon
mais c'est vrai
vous avez eu cette pensée mais oui
j'étais en train ne la lui proposait
quand vous êtes arrivé
vous êtes une nature merveilleuse oui
j'ai ce qui me disait lui aussi mais
écoutez moi bien ni le conte de perrault
gino ni personne au monde ne pourra
jamais mais posé par ce que je fais une
autre découverte en menant la vie d'une
femme libre ça que je ne suis pas libre
je suis votre femme
je me lève je me viennent à ma mère je
vous présente papables enchanté mais je
connais déjà
non vous ne la connaissez pas je viens
juste de la découvrir
c'est l'ère de venise qui l'a transformé
c'est la souffrance ma mère la princesse
geneviève vient de traverser une dure
épreuve
elle en sort éclairé purifier la
deuxième manche
quelle manche eh bien je me réjouis de
l'événement purifier ou non la princesse
à zones demeurent et c'est l'essentiel à
ses comptes periodico qui va se réjouir
de la nouvelle lune
la mère qui la prennent part vous s'il
vous plaît la pensée sat
je suis retourné chez moi je la con et
et ce n'est pas de ma mère dit aux
comptes le père gino de ma part que
naturellement l'offre ne tient plus
l'offre callen oui elle est au courant
venez les jeunes bière a chuté
brusquement trampo c'est comme si je
vous épouserais pour la seconde fois
mais valve nous tient debout mal à
zoomer pour sa femme pour la deuxième
fois
c'est décidément un garçon qui aime
beaucoup le mariage tu voulais vous dire
de la calotte raccommoder je m'y
attendais pour mieux à auffay tazoult de
ma charge de vous dire que l'enfant ne
tient plus qu'elle offre je n'aime pas
et paraît que vous êtes au courant
ah je vois dans des carottes puis je
m'entoure vous charger de lui dire une
chose
enfin la serait puisque je ne suis plus
bas à lca faire vos commissions
vous lui direz que je pars vous partez
pourquoi il ya des habitudes trop
encombrante
dans les premiers temps d'un mariage
excusez moi de ne pas vous en dire plus
son pain
mon petit mon cher petit ne sera
vraiment pas la peine d'avoir un passé
sentimental aussi riche que le mien si
je n'avais pu comprendre ce qui s'est
passé entre vous entre qui hantera zoom
sa femme et vous ou kyo et que s'est il
passé au juste
et bien ce que nous attendions tous
d'elle mais pas de vous ou à vous savez
j'espérais que vous au moins vous ne
souriez pas et je vous remercie pour ce
régime de faveur
tenez devant vous je me mets avoir honte
eh bien les y ait plus honte et accordez
moi une confiance que vous auriez
c'était bien inspirés de me témoigner
plutôt 7 à moi que vous auriez dû venir
tout raconter en tout cas à zone était
le dernier acquis le faire ça je ne le
regrette pas de naccarata c'est parce
que je lui ai tout dit qu'elle n'a pu
nous pardonner à tous les deux
maintenant ils se sont réconciliés
tout rentre dans l'ordre tout rentre
dans l'ordre
l'ordre des femmes n'est pas aussi
simple que vous le pensez lucho zune et
monfils et croyait que ces fiascos aux
amoureux me désole je suis navré d'avoir
à le reconnaître mais l'ordre de sa vie
amoureuse ne pourra jamais être basée
sur le chiffre 2 mai sur le chiffre 3 je
ne comprends pas je peux tout de même
pas vous dire à zoom sera toujours ce
qu'il vient d'être est ce qu'il a
toujours été
caen prenait benoît oui et je ne partage
absolument pas cet avis avant j'aurais
cru vous voulez vous en venir d'un
internaute à sa silhouette you can am en
fidèle et parfois un gros atout pour le
mari d'une femme qui ne l'est pas si je
comprends bien c'est vous maintenant
qu'il préconise rien à man pour la
princesse je ne viens attention jamais
l'idée ne m'en serais gagner un mois la
première vue puisque maintenant c'est
fait et défait la carotte
- justement c'est ce que je me demande
combien utile de le défaire vous
voudriez que je reste ne vous hérisser
par mon petit
comment vous dire le fond de ma pensée
sens vous scandalise et voyons vous
voulez partir bien bien mais écoutez moi
une forme comme la princesse geneviève
qui a pu faillir au huitième jour de son
mariage ne montre pas disons le une
exceptionnelle aptitude à la fidélité
personnellement je vais vivre dans dans
l'angoissé d'une récidive et qui aura
lieu dans dieu sait quelle circonstance
est quel genre on doit faire et jusqu'où
iront en pas eu d'enlèvement scandale et
cette fois alors l'éclat de rire à
montréal le
le ridicule à vie en zone sera le
premier avoue regretter à penser dans le
fond de lui même il aurait mieux valu la
solution à laquelle mon expérience me
permets moi de penser dès aujourd'hui à
s'il ne s'était rien passé
mais vous avez eu la faiblesse de
succomber mieux mieux
le courage de tout dire à zoug
maintenant le plus dur est fait et puis
je ne pense pas seulement à zoom lucho
je pense aussi à vous pour que vous lui
tirez vous vous ayez une semblable
défaillance il fallait que cette femme
exerça sur bois notre est plus puissant
que vous ne pouvez l'imaginer c'est vous
qui auriez pu la rencontrer le premier
et c'est vous qui auriez aimé au grand
jour la chronologie n'est pas une
justification en amour la zone vous la
prise en quelque sorte
en acceptant de l'est mais dans l'ombre
et dans l'ombre d'azul vous consentirez
le plus amer des sacrifices ce sera la
plus belle offrande que vous aurez
jamais fait à votre ami et sans qu'il
soit jamais en mesure de pouvoir
l'apprécier pas pour être franc jusqu'au
bout il faut se dire qu'au lieu de trois
malheureux à des échéances diverses et
bien il y aura trois heureux excusez moi
de ne pas vous suivre dans un
raisonnement aussi édifiant de la
carotte deux amis peuvent tous se
partageaient sauf une femme
ah oui préfère avec une femme se partage
entre deux ennemis je sais je sais tout
ce que ma suggestion peut avoir
d'énormes au premier abord je suis la
première à être étonné d'avoir pu la
faire elle est vraiment que ce soit vous
son fils me connesson jezzy le soir du
bal on vous aurait dit
c'est le conte perugini nom que vous
cherchez princesse oui a souhaité que je
lui parle de carlotta est ce bien utile
excellence il est toujours utile de
parler à une femme ont surtout lorsque
le mari l'y autorisent que comptez-vous
faire partir sans en expliquer votre
conduite et vous trouvez çà et là quand
vous entrez un soir de bal dans la
chambre d'une femme on pourrait presque
dire d'une jeune fille vous en sortez
lendemain et sous prétexte qu'elle a un
mari depuis huit jours allez vous allez
raconter votre prouver son mari et vous
plier bagage qu'elle se débrouille avec
lui qu'avez vous fait pendant ces huit
jours compte
je suis resté ici on prélève moi je vous
attendais mais une fois de plus vous
m'avez préféré un zoom à zone toujours
avant tout et avant moi vous pensez dans
l'avoir de tort quand vers huy non mais
lui a reconnu les siens il a beaucoup
changé vous savez oui beaucoup
il nous a pardonné aussi pense-t-il que
vous pouvez rester le parent gorge pas
tout
c'est pourquoi vous allez partir la
conscience légère apaisé vous choisissez
la solution facile pour vous moi jaurès
mais que voulez vous faire
j'attends
vous oubliez toujours que je suis novice
je dois tout apprendre ferait à monsieur
serait bien que je ne suis guère plus
expérimentés le soir du bal est ce que
nous n'avons pas cherché une solution
sable pour le soir du bon d'accord mais
nous sommes trompés mais nous pouvons
réussir aujourd'hui où nous avons échoué
ce soir là si vous partez que va-t-il se
passer
repose beaucoup plus aux absent que
présent ce que nous avons fait sera là
tous les jours entre elle et moi
de plus tôt ou tard ils me reprochent à
votre départ de nous écrivons ces
jalousies viendra école où grâce à vous
j'aurais appris par quel dérivatif on
peut la supporter je serai de nouveau
entraîner dans des excès pour lesquelles
je n'étais pas fait et si je reste si
vous restez
vous serez tout de suite moins
intéressant vous irez vous viendrez
comme vous l'avez toujours fait à zoom
vous aurez sous la main pour les 1000
petites affaires banales de la vie
quotidienne notre faute car après chaque
jour de son importance jusqu'au jour où
azzoun se dire en nous regardant mais
non ce n'est pas possible c'est une
hallucination il ne s'est jamais rien
passé entre eux et de plus pour moi
aussi ce serait plus facile
vous seriez de nouveaux lamidat zone et
pas l'homme qui a cessé de les écouter
si je reste je redeviendrai votre amour
vous le savez très bien et moi aussi
même d'un carlo talent sera yakaz une
qui ne sera pas cette fois parce qu'il y
ait des choses qu'on peut avoir une fois
mais pas deux
alors partez avant
la zone vous avez proposé paraît-il de
divorcer pour que vous me posiez
est ce exact
oui
et vous aviez accepté
vous l'auriez fait
oui
soper
[Musique]
c'est dit aussi c'est difficile mais que
vaut-il de refaire oui que faut-il faire
brasser chérie je fais servir le
champagne sur la terrasse pour fêter
votre grille et du champagne
excusez-moi de la reprendre lucho mais
je ne pouvais pas prévoir
tu voulais partir oui et une part plus
n'ont elles pas convaincu à la bonne
heure eh bien puisque tu ne pars plus
j'ai eu d'autres propositions à faire
voilà c'est encore une idée de ma mère
voilà le biais geneviève bien que
différente de mes autres femmes sera
toujours toujours en butte aux assiduité
de tous les coller à nouer fabrizzi de
la terre
comment écarter cette cour d' imbéciles
qui ne veut pas admettre que je puisse
avoir une femme fidèle
alors pour en août aucune chance si ce
qu'on a on le retrouvait en donnant à
manger une bière s'ils croient qu'elle a
déjà un amant et un amant de classe tous
ces petits messieurs resteront dans leur
coin
veux tu être cet amant
si je veux être pour la galerie nigo
tut afficherait partout avec elle vous
qu'on promet trier même de temps en
temps pendant qu'une petite légende
habile et disquettes
je fais confiance à ma mère circulerait
sous le manteau et nous serions
tranquille où tous les trois le champ de
blé pois l'éternel chandelier oui je
sais il ya quelques instants je te
proposer un tout autre rôle celui de
marie mais comme tu le vent a tourné et
de celui là je le garde
alors
alors je pense celui qui reste
bravo c'est entendu ma mère présent
répandre le bruit dans florence lucho
reste la bande de ma femme
la pièce que nous avons eu le très grand
plaisir de jouer ce soir devant vous est
de jean-bernard l'udc
la mise en scène est de jacques charon
[Applaudissements]
la chorégraphie est de jean-paul tommasi
le décor est de roger à
les costumes sont de donald cardwell
avec catherine ménétrier
philippe et s
claire vernet
thomas sertillanges
marcel britannique
l'us garcia bill
et henri tisot
[Musique]